starting now on book TV Mario Mills
talks about the life career and opinions
of Harper Lee author of To Kill a
Mockingbird miss mills moved next door
to Lee and her sister Alice in
Monroeville Alabama for 18 months and
spent time with the two women on a
regular basis this is about an hour 20
minutes
well let's see if this mics hot it is
good evening
right right on cubes I'm Jake Reese with
the Alabama book Smith and on behalf of
our dedicated staff of awesome
booksellers and this entire crew that
the Magnificent Alabama Theatre and the
geniuses at penguin press who published
the book the literary world has
anticipated for half a century it is my
privilege and pleasure to welcome you to
a Mockingbird tribute we also say a big
hi y'all to the viewers on c-span our
theater audience has enjoyed watching
and hearing Kathryn Tucker Windham on
the big screen tell personal Harper Lee
stories that before the start of the
main event each attendee has received a
signed first edition of the Mockingbird
next door with their ticket many of you
wanted extra copies for friends and for
gifts they are available at Alabama book
smith.com the folks sitting here will
also soak up the ambiance of this early
20th century movie palace that has been
lovingly restored to its original charm
the final perk of being present is that
one lucky patron will walk away tonight
with this 50th anniversary edition of To
Kill a Mockingbird with a book plate
signed by Harper Lee the rest of the
evening format will be opening remarks
by distinguished visit
a conversation with replies to our
enquiries questions from the audience
that you've written down as you entered
the theater and then the drawing for the
prize this podium will soon belong to
the author of the hottest book in
America we just found out about two
hours ago and you're the first to know
that it will debut this Sunday on the
New York Times bestseller list at number
Ford it's only been out a few days you
own a signed first edition it has been
praised and Damned by the New York Times
The Washington Post stood almost every
other newspaper radio talk show and
television news program out there
not to mention blogs tweets facebook
comments covering the planet many of you
like quite a few of the reviews we've
seen have an opinion before you've read
the book we ask that thoughtful literati
reserve judgment until you've heard the
presentation and the answers to the
questions posed we hesitate to take any
more of the speaker's time for much of
an introduction as the media has done
that job for us we will share that the
Georgetown Graduate owns a Pulitzer
Prize a marvelous sense of humor and a
respectful general manner that will be
apparent
as soon as you meet her even though she
spent quite a bit of time in our state
and watched many college football games
she will not tell us if she yells roll
tide or War Eagle
there is one controversy she does not
avoid when it comes to the Coke and
Pepsi Wars since her grandfather ran a
two-man coca-cola bottling plant back in
her hometown of Black River Falls
Wisconsin she maintains a strong
preference for Diet Coke ladies and
gentlemen please welcome back to Sweet
Home Alabama
Mario Nils
thank you so much just thrilled to be
here and see this gorgeous theater I've
been hearing about and reading about for
quite some time thank you Jake so much
for what you said and for putting
together just a magical evening
it was for me such a privilege to get to
know no Harper Lee and her older sister
Alice Lee and to have them share these
stories with me those they chose to
share and now privileged to share them
with you some of my favorite times with
Nell Harper for example were I've just
seen this table around the kitchen table
in the house that I rented next door to
theirs in Monroeville and I hope you'll
just pull up a chair to this kitchen
table with us let's share some stories
let's celebrate both no Harper Lee and
her remarkable equally remarkable sister
Alice Lee and also the friends and the
family in that town who so generously
helped me to understand the context of
their lives and of that town and please
pull up a chair let's have a good
chatter on the kitchen table
short and sweet well let's just we'll
just get right to it and then we'll been
edited for some time now as I was
preparing this book and I'm always
trying to see if I can use fewer words
which is not usually the first option
that comes to mind no editing this
evening okay you have carte blanche all
right I think a great opening comment if
you would share with the audience just
what went through your mind when you
were at the Best Western motel in
Monroeville Alabama the telephone in
your room rings and the voice on the
other end says hello this is Harper Lee
I wonder if we might meet and I tried to
keep my voice from raising a couple
arises a couple of octaves and felt as
if The Wizard of Oz had just placed a
call to my hotel room and was surprised
and just thrilled that the chance to
speak with her right away I think I had
the sense of what a down-to-earth person
she was and and not as shy as I think I
had pictured perhaps she asked if it
would be alright to come by the next day
and I said yes and she showed up at the
appointed time and began the first of
what was was many conversations over the
years to come
what am I one of the first times I
remember sharing a good laugh with her
the first of so many was when I was
telling her about my reason for being in
Monroeville which was that the Chicago
Library System had selected to Kill a
Mockingbird as its first selection in
one book when Chicago which was designed
to get people around the city from all
walks of life reading and talking about
the same book and so I was telling her
more about the activities in Chicago
around that selection the reason I had
been sent to Monroeville as a feature
writer for the Chicago Tribune
not with the thought of interviewing her
so much no and she was private but with
the thought
talking to people around town seeing
this place that that really is known to
readers around the world in the
fictional form that it helped inspire
anyway and so I was telling her that
they were showing the movie as part of
this in Chicago and she leaned over the
this little table actually that was in
that Best Western room and said of
Gregory Peck isn't he delicious and I
just thought all right this is gonna be
a different kind of conversation then I
thought and it was such a delight and it
was also the first indication of to me
one of the really touching things that
came out of that movie that I think
means the world to so many of us was a
friendship with Gregory Peck that lasted
through his death and after he died I
believe in 2003 with his widow Veronique
and with their family as well with
horton Foote the wonderful playwright
who won an Oscar for adapting
mockingbird to the screen and it was
there was something just wonderful all
those years later about hearing about
these men she referred to as some of the
last gentlemen I think she had
appreciation of the talent and also the
sensibility that came together to bring
us all that movie I'm glad you mentioned
Horton Flores is a there's a footnote
throughout the book you reference Harper
Lee's sense of humor and one of my
favorite little perks if you will was
when she received a phone call from
horton Foote and I believe his words
were God here explain that I will do
that and you even have his gentle deep
Texan gentleman's voice down now have
been quoted in The New York Times where
she was at an event and had said that
horton Foote after all these years now
looked like God only clean-shaven and we
were having breakfast not too long after
that had appeared and she told me that
she had answered the phone and this
modest Alice Lee used to always laugh
that it's always described as modest in
the newspaper stories so I apologize but
in their modest red brick house and a
quiet street in Monroeville the phone
rang and Nell said she answered it and
heard God here and these two old friends
caught up and at the end of the
conversation he simply said remember God
loves you
instead with such a twinkle in her eye I
was mentioning to Jake earlier today
who's been such a wonderful advocate not
only for this book but for so many and
truly appreciate what you've done see
where were we with horton Foote I think
you covered him with the shave in the
sense of humor okay
the audience before the main event
started got to see Catherine Tucker
Wyndham telling Harper Lee stories you
mentioned Catherine Tucker Wyndham in
your book and about listening to her
audio tapes tell us what brought that on
you know really all I needed in
Monroeville let me back up by just
giving you the context
in which I moved to Monroeville I had
known the Lee sisters for about three
years at that point they had been very
helpful in what became a long newspaper
story and some sidebars that I prepared
for the Tribune and encouraged me to
come back which I did and then spoke
with them about the possibility of
spending longer actually spending some
time living in Monroeville people in
Birmingham who know real estate prices
here will appreciate maybe that I had
the idea that maybe I could just find an
apartment over someone's garage I really
didn't need very much didn't want very
much but in a small town like that an
apartment that kind of a rental was
actually harder to come by that a house
for example to rent and a good friend of
theirs had suggested that I look at the
house two doors down from theirs where
by that time I had spent a lot of time
with both of them Madrid for a time in
Monroeville and I did say to both know
Harper and to Alice I wonder if that
wouldn't be kind of close for comfort I
don't even want to inquire about that if
that might be the case but they
encouraged me to look at it and I did it
was far more house than one person
needed but as somebody who lived in
downtown Chicago the rent that they
proposed charging this was a house that
they had hoped to sell but in a
difficult market we were willing to rent
they were going to charge me the
outlandish sum of six hundred and fifty
dollars a month for quite a nice house
which sounded pretty good to somebody
who lives in downtown Chicago however
when I told the Lee sisters about this
Nell's you know Harper's response was
towards highway robbery
I think she was offended by the idea
that I would pay more than she felt I
should be and the same friend pointed
out that the house right next door to
the lease had been vacant for some time
it too was for sale
this one had actually been for sale for
some time but hadn't sold it had some
storm damage and at that time just had
been on the market quite a while now
Harper and Alice offered to serve as
references encouraged you know look into
that and so I did and worked it out with
the young man who owned the house we'd
been transferred to another city that I
would rent it month-to-month while it
was on the market perfect place for me
to live and a way for him to have some
income while waiting to see in which
month this would sell well you could
imagine that in the middle of the night
I had to fight the urge to go out and
take that for sale sign out of the front
yard and and hide it in his garage I was
hoping that it would be available long
enough for me to spend a good amount of
time there and indeed it was I ended up
running that house for 18 months from
let's see the fall of 2004 until the
spring of 2006 and one of my favorite
things to hear when I picked up the
phone in my little modest but very nice
red brick house was hi hon youporn which
meant do you have a pot of coffee going
and might I come over and talk around
the kitchen table and we did that quite
often as well as we're pretty regulars
were regulars at McDonald's for talk
over coffee I remember having to wait
for no Harper in the parking lot we had
driven separate cars on that day and the
Tennessee game was on and she was asking
if I couldn't wait until the until she
had the final score for us to go in and
have our coffee and you know with Alice
Lee I would just mention one reason I
think that that no Harper referred to
her as Atticus in a skirt
is that she to like their father who was
an inspiration clearly for the Atticus
Finch character was it was an attorney
in a small town who practiced in this
quiet steadfast way and was fifteen
years older than the Harper and so knew
her as a girl when Harper was with
Scouts age for example it was a sisterly
relationship and yet there were times
when I felt she was as much mother as
sister with that age difference and of
course would let me know how her baby
sister was doing in New York those times
when Harper was was in New York as a lot
of you know she lived this really
interesting parallel existence in a way
between an apartment in in Manhattan and
then would take the train and spend time
in with Alice in Monroeville and I think
it tells you something about her that
she you know FHI had such a tie to both
of those very different places [ __ ]
Spacek wrote in her memoirs that
recording the audio for it to Kill a
Mockingbird was one of the best things
she did in her professional career you'd
mentioned the friendship that Nell had
with Gregory Peck earlier
Gregory Peck said in his biography that
Atticus Finch was his role of a lifetime
give us a perspective on why those two
giants of the entertainment world would
make such statements my understanding
from what I've read written by both of
them was that word privilege again that
is always for me the first one that
comes to mind when I think of how
generous they were in sharing their time
and their insights with me and I think
you know it's a it's a privilege to know
her and to know the people around her
it's also a privilege though I think
to try to honor a work that means so
much to so many people and has you know
remarkably so since it first was
published in 1960 I remember the first
time I saw Alice Lee who stands maybe
five feet tall on a good day very petite
going to their post office box on the
downtown square in Monroeville and and I
know some of you have been there and can
picture what I'm talking about she would
have her plastic bag from the grocery
store and would put in the
correspondence that all those years
later I think about 40 years later when
I first was spending time with them
would stream into that post office box
with people wanting to tell both of them
often times certainly no Harper what the
book meant to them and why and I think
it's a book that a lot of people feel a
personal attachment to they appreciate
it as a classic novel but I think
there's also a sense of maybe there's a
little bit of a guide to living for some
people and and characters that that a
lot of people feel attached to I'm
suspecting that there might be more than
one grandchild among these people who is
named Atticus or Harper or Scouts so you
can hardly see with these lights but
that's I'm thinking that's the same mad
if I were a gambling person and I think
that's one more reflection of of why it
means so much to people to try to do
honor to that to that work thank you
there were so many scenes in your book
that put a normal ordinary image in the
readers mind of this literary mysterious
woman would you elaborate on the
ambiance of feeding the Ducks having
mentioned coffee at McDonald's
we drank oceans dark oceans of coffee
overtime wardrobe shopping at Walmart
and I love is fitting quarters in the
washing machine in Excel Alabama houses
had a washing machine you know one of
the things that really appreciated most
as I got to know both no Harper and
Alice was how simply they lived and I
think for me one of the most instructive
things it may be in getting a glimpse at
their life that no Harper ever said was
on a drive and this relates to what
we're talking about this was on a drive
and that was you know one of the great
pleasures was exploring that part of the
steam went to better guides do not exist
clearly but it was we passed a beautiful
southern home grand home now Harper was
driving and Alice was in the passenger
seat and I was in the backseat so that
was kind of a common configuration but
we passed this beautiful old home and
Harper admired it but then she said one
thing about us referring to her and to
Alice is we can appreciate beauty
without needing to possess it and I
thought what a lovely look at the way in
my experience they kind of dealt with
the world of material things I think
people even now when they hear how
simply they lived our surprise and maybe
a little bit inspired by that I think
it's so easy to spend time on wardrobe
or on updating a house or on though on
things and in my experience they just
there was not as or on television that
would these were not things that that
took very much of their time in my
experience and it was it was refreshing
greater
that's a percept no that was a wonderful
perception that so many of us think of
her as mysterious but you made it seem
just as normal as blueberry pie in many
well and I have to say you know getting
a sense of them in that town where they
grew up for me one of the great
pleasures was that there was a story I
think for them on a drive just about
every property we drove by
they knew the story of the family that
had lived there and the feud that had
started three generations earlier in the
way it had been patched over maybe and
just all the stories that kind of that
lurk in that landscape and I often we
just tried to get a sense of what it was
like for them growing up there and and
being the ones who were listening to
those stories they had an Aunt Alice who
was their mother's sister who sounded
like quite a character right whenever
there was an Aunt Alice story it didn't
take long before I'd heard most of those
a time or two and so welcome hearing
about them more and I think you know
they grew up as a lot of people of their
generation did hear hearing stories that
weren't just information but it was that
pleasure in telling the story and
appreciating these characters a lot of
times in the town and in the family and
and having a bit of a sense of humor I
think about human foibles if that they
can be a source of great consternation
for all of us but also for humor and
that there's something human about that
that they appreciated I think that's
that's the word is human or for those
the most powerful parts of the book was
at that time when there was a confluence
of three major events in Harper Lee's
life the movie Capote was just coming
out the movie's infamous was just coming
out with Sandra Bullock playing Harper
Lee Catherine Keener played Harper Lee
Capote and at the same time
Charles shields biography was coming out
and you write and and we read the
influence and how that affected Harper
Lee's feelings and that in the book
you'll all see this where she got a copy
of the tape of Capote bootleg copy and
playing it at the Lee residence and they
have a little trouble both of them at
that time hearing so you are I love this
saying the words that nail said I did
not say would you set that scene
certainly and this exactly this isn't
yet another red brick modest house in
that neighborhood that actually belonged
to a friend of theirs who also had
become a friend of mine someone who was
a fellow Methodist in their congregation
and with whom they took a lot of out day
outings that kind of a thing and in this
crowd if you are as technologically
unsophisticated as I am but you want to
feel like a rock star in the tech world
hang out with people who are impressed
if you can press fast-forward you know
this but these were I kind of called
them my grey haired posse not only no
heart for an Alice but a lot of their
friends were were quite a bit older and
and so someone who knew how to work in
this case it was not even a DVD player
was a VCR came in handy and so one
evening I think no Harper as anybody
would not knowing how they would be
portrayed in something like that and in
wondering about this experience you
actually had being brought to the screen
through the imagination and the research
of filmmakers so she was she wanted to
see it and we went to this friend's
house who had
VCR she had hearing difficulties already
at that time as dead Alice Lee and so
the first remote button I was pushing
was the volume and that was we I pressed
play and we were going to watch the
beginning of this movie that she knew
was about to be seen by all kinds of
people around the country and I and I
said just tell me when it's loud enough
well of course it went up and up and up
and I think a lot of you can relate to
how difficult that is particularly she
got up as close as she could but it was
it was hard to hear all the dialogue and
so we fell into a routine where I would
pause after a line or two of dialogue
and tell her I wasn't sure that evening
whether I should be saying and then you
said or and then she said and and so I
settled on and then you said and it was
so interesting everywhere every couple
of lines really of dialogue to pause and
repeat it and she often had commentary
on that and and to go through the movie
that way and I couldn't help thinking
that evening as she was going home after
this what ended up being really quite a
special evening at the friend's house if
that was odd for me can you imagine what
it was like for her and I think on a sad
note she had she had been so
complimentary of philip Seymour
Hoffman's performance as Truman Capote I
think he was quite a big man in real
life and somehow managed to inhabit this
very petite figure and and very sort of
particular mannerisms of Truman Capote
who has I think all of you know had been
her childhood playmate for a time in
Monroeville and then adult friends other
not without bumps as adults and she's
predicted that evening well before he
was to win the Oscar that he would do so
and said it was uncanny the way he had
been able to capture something essential
about Truman Capote and I remember
making a note to myself that when the
book did come out that it would be
wonderful to be able to share a little
bit more about that with him and I was
actually driving to the airport here
when I got the news that he had passed
away and felt the sadness I think
everyone would who admires his work and
then a little extra because about the
lost opportunity to share with him her
appreciation that evening of the movie
she also told me that she wrote the
filmmaker of the other movie the other
proposing movie as they probably don't
like to be known but I believe it came
out second infant the one where Sandra
Bullock plays now and she had spotted in
a photograph about the filming of that
movie Sandra Bullock wearing I believe
it was white Bobby socks with black
pumps well know is not someone who spent
a lot of time as I mentioned worrying
about fashion but that was a little more
than she could take and I remember her
saying I never but told me that after
the movie came out she did drop a note
to the filmmaker and said you have
created a creature of such sweetness and
light and called her Harper Lee that I
forgive the socks
I can't see out the audience I'll ask
the staff to bring while I'm finishing
up these questions the staff will bring
me the audience questions and the stubs
so we'll get to the drawing eventually
but if you bring those up on stage we'll
appreciate it doctor oh that was quick
what took so long oh okay we can just
bring them on around that's okay
can you have a timeout thank you thank
you very much
I really want to ask this question I
don't know I'm sure many of the audience
knows and Jake before you even start
just thinking back like a writer I'm
ready to rewrite the chapter interest a
few hundreds ago I think you had started
to ask me about Katherine Tucker Wyndham
and after spending this much time with
kind of an older generation of Alabama
storytellers not only the LEAs but their
friends you're gonna have to forgive me
if I take some side trips I have been
tutored in that school of storytelling I
would say and I did but I think you
would ask me how it was that y'all came
to give me some of the tapes of
Katherine Tucker Windham telling those
marvelous stories of hers and that was
thanks to no not terribly long after I
had moved next door and was settling
into this house with these you know
unfamiliar clanks and wishes of this old
furnace and getting thoroughly spooked
at times there were some taxidermy on
the walls that didn't match my decor at
home and it took a little getting used
to
I considered on the first night I was
there hanging towels over the deer head
and there were a couple other creatures
I wasn't entirely sure what they were
because I just felt like those marble
eyes were kind of following me as I
I'm backing my books but I decided that
would be creepy or even than just having
the marbleized following me so I learned
to live with my roommates but it was
lonely sometimes I have lupus which is
an autoimmune disorder that can leave
you quite tired and so I spent a fair
amount of time both in Chicago and then
while in Monroeville in bed and resting
at home and it could it could be lonely
and I've missed having a voice in the
room
there'd been damaged to the antenna for
television there so there wasn't much
television which kind of broke me of
that habit for the most part which was
kind of a side benefit I would say of my
time there and I couldn't get NPR which
I will admit as a as a good Chicago girl
I was used to my to my NPR the the
reception would fade as you got closer
to Monroeville and I just wanted I just
want to hear some people who've made
that drive made a piece
I just wanted sort of a friendly voice
in the room with me to keep me company
and and now Harper came up with the
perfect three word remedy Katherine
Tucker Wyndham and came over one day she
would always you know come in through my
kitchen door and good Alabama neighborly
fashion and and said here these are for
you and they were the the first few of
as many as I could find of Katherine
Tucker Windham tapes talking about
growing up as she did and I think there
were some real parallels to the way no
Harper grew up and so they were a
delight can you imagine a better voice
to have in the room with you especially
if you're gonna play a tape three times
four times five times
I always remember her saying that she
paused often in her stories and friends
asked her why and she realized the
explanation might be that her father
would pause I believe was it to light a
pipe Jake I know that
you her friend and so perhaps that was a
habit she had picked up but she was also
somebody that that I think now admired
for the way she captured a particular
way of life when she was growing up and
since no was able to do a more or less
reasonably good job of that herself I'd
say that was a pretty good
recommendation well you've given me two
great lead ends I can't introduce
everybody we are so many celebrities in
the audience but Catherine Tucker
Wyndham children dil C hilly is here and
Ben Wyndham sitting over here at some
they have written a new afterward
Catherines original book 13 Alabama go
see Jeffrey is approaching its 50th
anniversary in the University of Alabama
press is reprinted and the children have
written it afterwards it's a perfect
book I know where you can get a copy no
more vodka
[Laughter]
my impression I just say briefly was
that they had such admiration that no
Harper and Alice did of course for their
father and then the role he played in
their small town and that seemed to be
one of the things that's true there too
yeah yeah
you gave me another great introduction
those of you who know and have read
Laura Hillenbrand to the greatest books
of all time Seabiscuit and unbroken I
think many of you know that for most of
the time she wrote those books she never
left her room she had chronic fatigue
syndrome and wrote literally most of
those books in her bed
we know that health has been a factor
with you both in the time you spend in
Monroeville and writing this book like
Laura Hillenbrand you spent the majority
of the time writing this book in bed
again
tell us how in the world that was well
you know I would be there I did write
most of the book in bed with lupus
frequent rest is a help and so I would
kind of work in whatever chunks I could
but a lot of times just there and in my
apartment in Chicago in bed and to me it
was it was it was the power of books to
transport you to another time to another
place I remember when I first read To
Kill a Mockingbird I was in ninth grade
at Madison West High School in my
hometown of Madison Wisconsin snowy day
but feeling transported sitting in our
old creaky overheated library to the
streets of make'em and there was an
element of that in writing the book it's
frustrating not as particularly as a
journalist one of the things that was
appealing to me about journalism was the
chance to be out and about traveling and
meeting people and so it was frustrating
when I was having to spend large chunks
of time in bed and and alone mostly I
have wonderfully supportive family and
friends and my mom Carla Knowles is here
traveling with me and making all the
difference as usual and so I had good
company in that sense and I still had
Katherine Tucker Wyndham believe me in
the room with me on those tapes but it
also was a chance at a time when when it
was frustrating to be to be having to be
at home so much to travel by way of
written word reading it and writing it
and of course in the writing of this I
was reliving a lot of the experiences
I've had in Monroeville and felt quite
often that I was sort of as a wrote of
the Lee's helper Julia Marlon
remarkable woman in her own right who
was their helper when I was living next
door I kind of felt like I was
resurfacing sometimes in that bedroom at
the end of the day after spending time
in my imagination and in my research and
my notes in Monroeville and that was
true of Julia motherland' who also very
generously spent a lot of time with me
telling me about her life as an
african-american woman who grew up at
the time she did and was a nurse in a
midwife for many years and would tell
those tales and then you know that spell
that that he knew how to cast that know
and Alice I would say were masters of
the art where you almost forget where
you are for a minute and the resurface
and remember for me it was it was a way
to be out in the world even when I
really wasn't and and you know there's a
little bit of of faith and hope involved
in such a solitary process that that the
time will come when you're sharing those
stories with other people and how
remarkable it is to be here doing that
with you tonight
this was such a gift that they both
shared with me and I want to be just a
good to share that gift with all of you
there were stories that they that they
didn't want to share and as I mentioned
in the book a lot of times to spare the
feelings of a friend or relative who was
part of a story that that they shared
but not for the book and yet there were
there were so many I think that that
they delighted in telling and we're
ready to share and it was just such a
gift they gave me and that that I'm so
glad to be sharing with all of you now
thank you very much
very thoughtful a wonderful moment maybe
one of the most wonderful moments of the
many wonderful moments that fascinated
me was the road trip you had now took to
New Jersey would you tell us a little
bit about that long road trip with
pleasure I was going while I was living
in Monroeville I had a car that that
their good friend Thomas Lane bus who
they used to call an allegedly
semi-retired minister Methodist minister
he had gone with me to buy a car that he
dubbed old blue because I think all cars
in that part of the world need a
nickname if they possibly can have one
so that became old blue and I was going
to be driving the old blue from
Monroeville to princeton junction new
jersey not terribly far from from new
york where were nel would be returning
before long I was going to visit friends
and then went on to Chicago and so she
came along as my passenger she didn't
fly and the train which used to go to
evergreen Alabama I know some of you are
familiar with evergreen no longer went
as close and and so we decided she
decided that she would join me on this
trip well I decided I needed to be
prepared for any contingency so I got
water bottles I got orange traffic cones
I joined triple-a and I wondered if I
should get a sign to put on my car like
the taxis in New York but this one would
say please drive carefully national
treasure on board I didn't want to have
to answer to the nation if if anything
happened on that drive but we actually
had other than me hitting a rut in their
driveway before we were two minutes on
the road
I think her comment was I'm trying to
remember exactly way to get off to a
good start something along those lines
we actually did end up having having a
smooth trip and can you imagine a better
person to be drinking more coffee with
and and talking about the country going
by our windows as we drove remember
thinking that all those years she took
the train that the country hadn't seen
much of Harper Lee but Harper Lee had
seen a lot of the country she did like
to travel took the train to Los Angeles
when I was living in in Monroeville for
a library fundraiser that I believed at
that point
veronique Peck Gregory pecks Widow was
involved in and that support of
libraries that was one of the reasons I
first got to know them I and her
friendship I think with the pecks was
reason enough to take a train from New
York to Los Angeles and and then go from
there to eventually make her way to
Alabama when now asked you to talk or
when she wanted to talk off the record
like she mentioned the town's biggest
gossip or other areas that might be
extremely sensitive what was your
reaction as as a reporter when Nell said
this is off the record don't write that
that that was absolutely what I would
respect and no and I there may be people
here I think who've had the privilege of
spending time with her and know that she
has this kind of gesture with her index
finger when she's making a point when I
was spending time with her she would
sometimes say now that's off the record
don't don't include that in the book or
would say now you put that in there
certain stories that she especially
hoped I would share and so my feeling
was of course that that was that I
wanted to respect her wishes and and
made note of those things but I would
say again they were actually more candid
than I might have predicted and but did
have a sense that sort of the burden of
fame which was clearly Harper Lee and
and Alice Lee as well as someone who was
involved with her affairs
all those years felt personally and
didn't feel it needed to extend to
friends and relatives who hadn't signed
up for that any more than necessary a
lot of times I think you know these were
stories that were that sort of
appreciation of human foibles of the
excesses of people of the characters in
a small town but that they didn't that
they didn't want to be the source of
hurt feelings and and so those of those
were ones that that I didn't share
that's I knew that I wanted you to share
that with the audience and and while on
that subject before we get to these
questions and holy Michael this is a
smart bunch of folks these are
incredible I'm embarrassed these are a
lot better than mine
before we dig in to these father
doubters and naysayers I I'm going to
take personal privilege there was a
witness to one of the dinners that you
write about and she was a she is a close
friend and now as a former neighbor for
much longer than you were a neighbor and
we've had several conversations about
you and about your book and she shared
with me and I got her permission to
mention this that you were just the
smartest person and the greatest sense
of humor and that you and nail cut up
like old old friends and Julie said I
could tell that wave Julie hello I
haven't seen you submit since that night
many years ago it's so great to see you
we were I was thinking that one thing
about spending time with no heartburn
with Alice was they're so witty that it
kind of raised the game of everybody at
the table in the sense that I think you
you wanted to have good shared stories
to share yourself and there was a lot of
laughter at those tables as I recall
there was quite a bit that night and I
believe her phrase was I have a Yankee
for you there was there was someone from
out of town
perhaps north of mason-dixon line who is
also with with us that evening she was
also concerned that most of my friends
there were in their 80s and 90s I mean
there's
which is sounding younger and younger to
me all the time but that there weren't
as many young people for me to spend
time with and so that night was a chance
I think to do that as well yeah that was
great - nice to see you thank you for
coming Judy my last request for you
before we get into these and it's that
would be a daydream for the audience you
mentioned in the book the possibilities
of what it would be like to have on our
bookshelves
if nelle Harper Lee had written a few
more books and some of the occasions
that you were with her that it seemed
like she ought to have written a book
about race about community about the
minister who murdered for insurance
money and I'd like for you to touch on
that if you would and the evening that
you ran across the east asian immigrants
and --nails
thought so that's a whole bunch of
things for you to cover before we get
anybody's if you would all right well
let me just briefly I'll start with the
last one and then you can bring me back
if I take a side trip or to the evening
I believe you're referring to was a
dinner at a Mexican restaurant in
Monroeville those of you who spent time
there know that the dining options as
now said are somewhat limited there are
some wonderful places but it ends up
being a matter of well do we go to
David's catfish house tonight or
Radley's south 40 and so we have decided
on a lark to try a Mexican restaurant
that was sort of on the outskirts of
town and when we were there there
weren't too many people at the
restaurant but there was a very long
table of people whose who are of Indian
origin of East
origen who know was so fascinated by it
was it was generations of this extended
family and more I think they were people
primarily who ran motels in that larger
area and some had come more recently
some had been in in that part of the
state a long time but she was just so
interested in that as a subculture and
and how did it work and how did those
families interact and how did it work
when people were starting with nothing
that they were able to get a foothold
economically and socially and I had very
few practical skills I will say I had a
terrible sense of direction I'm not a
kook but I do speak Spanish and so that
was an evening when I was able to help
with something practical which was she
wanted to ask the waitress who who was
still learning English more about those
families and so so there I was asking a
waitress from Mexico about the families
from India and translating for now who
was so interested and animated and I
think I was you know captivated by how
social classes work and how people
interact and what changes and what
doesn't and full of questions kept
apologizing and then kept right on
asking the waitress more questions about
how how all that work and I and I you
know I did have a paying that evening
that I would love just selfishly to read
the book that she could write about that
part of the experience in that part of
Alabama or conversely there was a
possible death penalty case in
Monroeville after the murder of a
physician and his wife terribly said
case where their son killed his parents
and ended up committing suicide before
this became before it went to trial but
it looked like it would be a death
penalty case and so we spent time
talking about
that issue there were other occasions
where I just couldn't help thinking how
much people would would like to know
what she thought about that and in the
story she could tell and and I felt how
much he came to life a lot of times
talking about about those kinds of
things and about the stories that that
tell you more about issues than anything
else although of course that was her
decision and only she knew what was the
right thing for her to do and why but I
have to say there are times I've
pictured a small or large but at least
some volumes that that might have been
written had she chosen to continue
publishing after she did those were very
thought-provoking and I reread those
several times and we can all daydream
what if I could remember now Harper
telling me not too long after I hadn't
moved there I think she was talking
about being in law school which she had
attended and said that the dry
technicalities were what were her words
of law school and a law practice didn't
interest her but the human stories did
and the drama of the trials and I think
that's one reason it was so interesting
to to know her and Alice Finchley his
Atticus in a skirt in that context
because Alice was a master of detail and
of dry technicalities and and certainly
had the same appreciation I think for
the the human stories behind them but
also was very patient and in dealing
with all the methodical aspects of doing
that job well we're not going to be able
to get to these several hundred but
we'll go through as many as we can
just a side trip if I'm sorry no no they
just I love this right off the bat I
can't wait to hear answer wish I'd
thought of this
mmm-hmm someone that didn't sign their
name but said I think a book about Alice
would be interesting would she be open
to that and are you interested in
pursuing that oh my goodness well alice
is worthy of as many books as you could
possibly read about her honestly I've
when I first moved down there friends of
theirs said people who don't know them
as sisters don't believe us when we say
that that Alice miss Alice says she has
known around town is every bit as
remarkable in her own way and original
as no Harper and that certainly was my
experience as well from the start so I
don't know the answer to their specific
questions to your specific question
whoever had that but I would say just as
now Harper had had a singular
perspective really on what it meant to
write the book that she did and then
have the response that she did all these
years Alice Lee too was in a was in a
singular position in a lot of ways and
it really was keeper of the family
history and wanted to do was preserve as
many of those stories as as she was able
to share and that she had time to share
hi was ginger in the beginning about the
question of a lot of their friends were
pleased that she was willing to record a
lot of the family stories that that
probably would go with her when she died
if she didn't she just had a memory and
it and now is a hundred and to practice
law until she was a hundred that nobody
else had and so there was a sense of
urgency not only on her part but on on
that of the other people who they
encouraged to speak with me but they
were they were much more matter-of-fact
about it Alice used to say to me they
recommend they they gave me assignments
regularly one was to visit a lot of
different churches in that area
to visit white churches and black
churches and Baptist and Methodist and
Pentecostal and the breakaway version of
all of those that develop over time and
in other denominations but they also
wanted me to speak with some of the
people who had known their family who
maybe were a little less prone to
embellishment shall we say then than
some of the people who had shared
stories publicly about the Lee family
over the years and so Alice would say no
I want you to talk to so-and-so do that
early on while he still has his marbles
just matter of fact and Anne knows
there's a wonderful photograph of her
that ran as the lead photograph with my
newspaper story where you see a certain
intensity in her eyes and I that same
gaze saying you talk to so-and-so while
they're still above ground and and so
the chance to preserve those stories I
think was was one of the most meaningful
parts of this for me this is a tough
question I can't wait to hear your
answer you may you may give up the
question is if you had to describe
Harper Lee in just one word what would
it be oh my goodness
original I think you know she wrote a
book of such universal appeal but one of
the reasons I think that those
characters have have captivated so many
people in so many countries for so many
years is is they're originals there's
something Universal about about those
characters and yet they're also each of
them I think real individuals and and I
would say the same of now that there's
such a spark see there's a phrasing to
kill mockingbird about the spark of
fresh adventure in someone i someone's
eyes in the book it was reference to
that leaving someone i someone's eyes
but that was so much true of her and of
Alice Lee and part of what made it it I
always feel there was something
predictable in the good sense of the
word I would say about a lot of what
they shared with me as I got to know
them better and spent so much time with
them but there was also always something
original I wasn't quite sure what she
would have to say about something and
that and that made for such for such fun
hey this next question says you've won a
Pulitzer Prize for journalism and of
course Miss Lee one for literate or are
there any traits you believe most
Pulitzer Prize winners share well first
of all I would make the distinction the
very large distinction that of course
she won the Pulitzer Prize for that
beautiful novel I was part of a large
team of reporters that worked on a
series called gateway to gridlock about
O'Hare Airport and and you know this was
very much a team effort and and so I
would make that distinction I was I was
one of many
fascinating project to work on I think
was now now and others I've met
including a woman who I described in the
book a friend who also went to pull
surprised you know there was a feeling
of doing something that mattered to you
that you that had nothing to do with
simply the need to make a living
although certainly that's I was a
consideration in any profession but a
sense of a purpose that I think gave
meaning to the lives of the people I
know who've done that work and and to
their projects a sense of it being about
something more and I'll just mention
briefly a friend of mine from the
Chicago Tribune named Julia Keller won a
Pulitzer Prize in 2005 for a series that
was really about the randomness of fate
and it recreated a tornado that swept
through a small town in Illinois and the
randomness of fate in part was that you
know this was one of those tornadoes we
know too well in the Midwest that where
there's very little warning and in this
town people who somewhat randomly turned
right on one side of Main Ave a Main
Street and went into a tavern on one
side survived those who happen to turn
left and went into the other didn't and
just seemed so random and so her series
beautifully recreated what it was like
to be in that town when that happened
but also how people came to terms with
that part of that experience and and she
was awarded the Pulitzer Prize in 2005
for future writing and that was you know
one I was living in Monroeville at that
time I was in Chicago for some doctors
appointments see my rheumatologist but
when that was announced I believe that
was in April
I was there and we had a party for her
at my apartment I live not too far still
from the Chicago Tribune
so now got a kick out of the story that
I told about ordering a cake to
celebrate this achievement from a
fancier bakery than I had ever ordered a
cake from they actually delivered it to
my door I didn't really know that was a
concept until they told me they would do
that but because her name was Joo is
Julia Keller but she would often get
Julie sometimes and and so I told the
person who was and I was recounting this
to know when I returned to Monroeville
not long after this and yet another
kitchen table although this was that of
a friend that I had told the people who
are writing on the top of the cake that
I would like it to say congratulations
Julia pulitzer-prize 2005 but I said now
Julia sometimes gets Julie could you
please be sure that you spell it with an
A and I don't mean to be a pain in the
neck but could you even read it back to
me and the fellow had quite a heavy
accent I couldn't quite place it but I
wanted to be sure that that he was
understanding me better than I was able
to understand him during that
conversation on the phone and he said
what an honor that's marvelous
julia ju li a we have it no worries well
right before a bunch of people from the
chicago tribune then were coming over to
celebrate that cake was delivered and as
i told now i picked up the lid and my
heart sank because it said it did say
congratulations Julia but then it said
poet surprise 2005
which of course is something we still
call her all these years later and she
is quite lyrical so I think it's an
appropriate name but now got such a kick
out of that story I share that at the
home of their of another mutual friend
eyelid Jeter but also you know I think
one of the things I so respected about
both of them as they were talking about
their experience was you know the real
respect for achievement as opposed to
simply celebrity for its own sake and I
think the Pulitzer what it was was
meaningful naturally for her and
something that so clearly was about
achievement and and not about Fame and
also was something that their father
lived to see her receive and I know that
gave it an extra level of meaning as
well he died unfortunately before the
movie came out but but lived to see that
achievement and that was something that
all those years later there was you know
there was still a little spark of a
pride in that achievement when we would
when we spoke about it and when I told
her about my friend the poet surprise we
I noticed several poets in the audience
so you need to create a poet surprised
that you would be worthy this is one I
don't know if you'll answer but are you
pleased no I choose to say no comment
whatever it's about oh no no you answer
those are are you planning to attend
your college reunion next year or your
Sax's oh my goodness is there a
Georgetown person in this audience hello
I was I was I graduated from Georgia the
short answer is yes I would love to I
missed the last one because I was in the
hospital in Monroeville dealing with
some lupus problems and so heard about
it from a friend by phone and would love
to I'd also add that although my older
friends in Monroeville rolled their eyes
at the thought that I know what it's
like to be getting older and 51 now my
my classmate as a freshman at Georgetown
was Patrick Ewing who of course went on
to pay for the mix well imagine when I
was still feeling pretty young listening
to the commentators who would say and
there goes poor Patrick Ewing javelina
knows me he's an old man now and he's so
he went and he was we were class of 85
so I would love to return okay well hope
that answers your question we discussed
this earlier in the afternoon tell us
the tale you didn't tell in the book oh
my goodness
did you have one in particular no no no
this no these are my these folks out
here mmm
boy that was none of the painful things
was I tried to select the stories that
that were typical of my experience that
were in that category of pull up a chair
and listen to their stories one of the
ones that I touched on in the book but
didn't write as much about as I would
have liked to was was this Aunt Alice
that I mentioned their mother's sister
who who like one no Harper Lee and one
Alice Finchley had a playful sense of
language that was that was such fun and
that I think was part of a way of
looking at the world really and so they
would they would have Aunt Alice isms
was how I came to think of it that they
would bring up every now and then and
one of my favorites was the term Sipho
lune which having been through some of
the weather there were having a bit of
weather today was another expression I
remember when the you know trees were
ready to blow down
Sipho lune was an Alice's term she had
created for whether that was a cross
between a cyclone and a typhoon a scythe
balloon and
and I think there was some amusement on
both of the sisters part that she had
gotten a digital clock I think was also
familiar with heart medication perhaps
and never could quite get it straight
that this was not a digitalis clock
telling the time they had such affection
for her and and for some of the other
relatives that that we talked about mr.
Nash every now and then no Harper would
say oh I'm driving like mr. Nash and mr.
Nash was married I believe to their aunt
kitty who herself referred to him as mr.
Nash a bit of a more formal generation
and mr. Nash would would save money by
driving rather slowly and conserving gas
so if someone including no Harper
herself was driving a little bit slowly
that day they were driving like mr. Nash
and I sometimes will think I don't have
a car in Chicago one thing I love about
living in downtown Chicago is is not
needing a car but if I'm home in
Wisconsin and and driving a car
someplace and go a little bit slowly I
think to myself while I'm driving like
mr. Nash and that makes me think of a
Harper itself as a name and I think some
of you would be familiar with this but
maybe not most and and whenever I hear
that the Beckham's in England for
example have a little have a daughter
Victoria Beckham and her soccer star
husband David Beckham that they have a
little girl named Harper or all the many
other children's celebrities or not that
are named Harper I think of how that
name came to be and that it really was a
thanks to and and otherwise forgotten I
believe selma pediatrician who was able
to come up with the formula that the
third of the three Lee sisters Louise
Lee as a baby she was unable to digest
formula
and in this pediatrician finally after
they had made the rounds to other
doctors and were desperately worried
that that Louise Lee as an infant
wouldn't survive if she couldn't begin
digesting formula they came across a
some of pediatrician by the name of
doctor William Harper and ten years
later Louise Lee was 10 years older than
the Harper more or less when when one
nelle Harper Lee came into the world in
an upstairs bedroom in their old house
on Alabama Avenue that name was was a
thanks in part to to this pediatrician
who I'm sure could not imagine would
would he had would know that his name
was in you know in the streets of London
and all kinds of places that that he
couldn't imagine being a part of that
was another nugget that was wonderful to
read in your book that there's one I
don't know that we that we knew would
take a couple of more and then the old
clock on the walls ticking did either
nail our Alice address the Truman Capote
issues concerning the probability that
he wrote to kill a monkey oh yes just a
wee bit
and I think Catherine Tucker Windham in
that wonderful video that I just saw for
the first time what a treasure and I
thought she's so captured the the no
Harper in and also Alice in a couple of
those stories that I spent all that time
with I'm sorry tell me the tell me the
I'm I've I've found a mental side trip
here about Nell or Alice addressing the
oh yes yes might have written to kill
her monkey yes I think Alice's phrase
about that was that's the biggest lie
ever told and it was a source of
consternation as Catherine Tucker
Wyndham mentioned in those comments he
cannot be any credence put to that
theory there might be some question as
to how much know Harper assisted anyway
Truman Capote perhaps more than she was
explicitly thanked for example in in
cold blood where she where she went to
Kansas with him when to kill a
mockingbird was still with the publisher
hadn't yet come out although she had
finished it and as those of you who
watch those movies or know about their
history no she went to Kansas and and
helped him research these murders that
had taken place in a farmhouse there and
I don't know about the writing of the
book but I do know how helpful it was to
him to have someone who so easily could
put people at ease in that small town he
was you know he was such a character I
think and and it was helpful to him to
have someone who who people felt they
knew I think after not talking to her
for all that long and and really was
quite a help I think in the researching
of in cold blood she also told me that
incidentally that was I think already at
that point in his career there was some
sense that maybe he was floundering a
bit I know she said she felt this was a
good and serious project that he could
pursue and she wanted to be a help
and I think certainly certainly was and
and shared as well that fascination for
for criminal justice for the stories of
of a crime like that and then what
happens as more as found out about the
crime and the criminals and an in cold
blood was really became I think one of
one of the early examples of what he
called a nonfiction novel of a narrative
that he was attempting to tell in a
novelistic fashion but ideally sticking
to what they had learned in their
research about what truly had happened
in that case thank you this this might
take the rest of the evening what things
did you find inspired Harper Lee hmm
she had such an appreciation for how
hard people worked I think especially as
someone who knew the Depression and of
course captured it into such an iconic
way in to kill a mockingbird was always
impressed
whatever somebody's background whatever
their family history with people who had
that perseverance to work hard a lot of
times for not very much pay provide for
families it was there was I think there
were there were values from their father
that they both talked about that you see
in that book that you see in the way
they lived and that was one of the ones
actually that I think was most striking
in my conversations with them their
appreciation of how hard it was for a
lot of families not only in the
depression but but but at the time I was
living in Monroeville and in the respect
for the people who found a way if they
if they had the opportunity
to provide for a family and to persevere
over overtime and I think an
appreciation that although like a lot of
families in the depression they
certainly knew hardship they knew people
who live so close to to the margins to
how much a family can get by in a year
and an appreciation of how many people
managed to do that and in such difficult
circumstances
and and perhaps some feeling that
they're both discussed with me in their
own ways but but there was a commonality
of concern that maybe what what a lot of
us now would consider what you need to
get by is is inflated that the
necessities of that that there's a
difference between need and want and and
it's maybe a problem of an effluent in a
technologically advanced country that
that wants can begin to seem like need
and that and that puts pressures on
people that maybe they don't have to
have well as we are just about to run
out of time before we have better do and
have this little piece of business about
this little book here do you have any
parting remarks for these folks here in
Alabama all the ones that have come from
Kansas City and Florida and Tennessee
and Mississippi well on a lighter note
all I will say in the interest of being
able to leave the theater physically
intact is that I did write roll tide in
a book in Washington thank you
ago but it was if I see any orange and
blue out there it was only because the
very nice gentleman who was who had
written that looked at me and said this
is a gift and I did have to mention to
him that good friends of the lesion in
Monroeville have a son who is my
honorary brother he always introduced me
as his sister he's a man in his 40s who
has Down syndrome and and I think he had
a special friendship with with no Harper
always he was someone who didn't want a
thing from her other than her friendship
and her her playful sense of fun which
he most definitely had in spades and
Kenny might be his name is Kenny Croft
and he's a ham so he won't mind me
mentioning his name Kenny Croft might be
the world truly no hyperbole biggest
Auburn fan he has a collection of
memorabilia that people have brought to
him every t-shirts mug etc known to man
there's a Christmas tree that has a burn
ornaments on it Kenny has collected and
so to balance my role tied in the book
in Washington I will also say that I did
from my hotel room in New York yell over
the line to Kenny
War Eagle
hey just about just about even steven we
probably best leave that subject it's
time well on behalf before we have the
drawing while most of the audience is in
a good mood we appreciate your taking
time out to come to Birmingham Alabama
we loved it but many of us did not have
a preconceived notion of you are the
book are writing about our nelle Harper
Lee you did it in a marvelous manner and
in a respectful manner I feel much
better having read it and thank you for
your gift to the literary world thanks
to penguin press and before we thank all
of you for coming somebody's really
going to be happy but I wanted
everything before she draws the name and
before everybody's mad because she
didn't draw yours
let's tell this young lady how much we
appreciate
[Applause]
if I look the Georgetown person wins the
drawing well it's gonna be mighty
suspect well I want you to know how to
pick his seat because these are strictly
by seat numbers so my cousin I'm sorry
great ceremony I will not look not move
and I will pull from the middle pull
from the middle okay well I'll put your
glasses on the right first first first
read the road all right we'll do this
for some drama appropriate to a theater
and the road that has the winner is the
row would be J James alright and seat
number are you ready all right we are
row J seat 26 this is for you row JC 26
I can't see my cousin there you are and
your name is Pam thanks Pam enjoy your
book from hell
Pam from Pearl City it sounds like a
Paul Finebaum book in the booth as soon
as we say our good nights would you kill
these mics so you won't hear us talking
back thank you so much for coming we
appreciate it
please [ __ ] we're gonna get her back for
that second book
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]